بسلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر اشهد
ان اله الا الله
الله اشهد
ان
اله الا
الله اشهد
ان
محمدا رسول
الله اشهد
ان
محمد
رسول الله
حي على
[Silence]
الصلاه حي على الصلا
حي على الفلا
[Silence]
حي على
الفلاح
الله اكبر
الله الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
ان الحمد
لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله
من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا من يهدي
الله فلا مدل له ومن يدلله فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله صفي بخلقه
وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه ونس
الامه وكشف الله تعالى به غمه وجاهد في
الله حق جهاده حتى اتاه اليقين اما
بعد وقال الله سبحانه وتعالى في القران
المجيد وفرقان حميد بعد ق اعوذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا
ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانم مسلمون ثم اما
بعد فان استق الكتاب كتاب الله تعالى وخ
هدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر امور
محدثها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل
ضلاله في النار رب اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي
امري واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه قولي اللهم
لا سحل الا ما جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل الحزن
اذا شئت سحلا ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
العلي العظيم الله ربنا وفقت ورجاؤنا
ومولانا فنعم
الله
[Silence]
‏alles الله سبحانه
وتالى اتقوا الله ح تقاته ولا تمت الا
ومسلمون ‏fear your lord as it is
rightfully for you to do to fear him and
do not die until you are in the state
subm to
ask
endm not take from world until he is
satisfied with us as a believer and when
he does take us from this world our last
words of the
t as the c
عليه
واللام a year
passed new
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عنه
عن عمر رض
عن عمر
رضي
حابس اللهانه
‏confused i said
i one
m the
next to of one m the b of next one cling
me working on
اخ حث صلم
[Silence]
عليهه ض
خدا حودا
خ اتق في
نسائكم الله سبهالى
[Silence]
علسلام يه
‏my wife h from and to tr and i would
girl in the house run around and some
and always say oh this is the daughter
of the neb just comes over here because
she likes hanging out and then one my
wife me you know she years old maybe her
father would be be little more easy have
a little r in his heart he will have
little
mercy so i my husb this ister and he say
no
[Silence]
‏face
‏sisteres
as have the highest
rat
killing highest because they
[Silence]
‏are
the just
people حديث رول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏you
‏doings الله سلام
[Silence]
حثه ض عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ث
[Silence]
‏come
‏no
easy are
[Silence]
‏person الله
‏mar
mother who
mother my mother so
wife
there what are
[Silence]
‏gener
anding
womeh
likees 247
‏not
tell let them
ex
example
all
all he never seen
[Silence]
‏what
رسول الله
صلحه عليه
واللام محمد وهذ محد صل علسلم
رسول الله
عشه رضي الله
عنثر
يئه رضي عن صل علس
‏alling
prepend shoes
[Silence]
‏not responsible for those
things have to understand there is more
women
present to that this pic and this emic
ofce killing us killing us inter
س عليه
واللام
easy وتالى
[Silence]
‏we have to beant
ofes
wom how are
[Silence]
صل
الله سهال
[Silence]
حث تسمع استغفر الله كم
ستغفر الغف الرحيم
الحمد لله الحمد
للهدد ل يلد و ي ود
عن ابن عباس رضي الله عنه قال ق رسول الله
صل الله عليه وسلم خيركم خيركم لاهله وانا
خيركم لاهله او كما قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام عرضي
عن رسول الله صل
علس عليه
والسلام ‏and is we into tree
andies fit best those things fit lify
and that's for us and we lecture others
on the same things that
okay
theam was per in every shap every form
in every place if he was house his was
‏have
to we have to those things we have to
why we choose to get marri and why are
married we have why when
marry wife
compl unfor
[Silence]
الحد
رب
every
ed you the educate toar
andi of make living
‏as عليه
الصلام واللام
[Silence]
99.9% ises
disy
99.9% unfor
not
no
as time rning
by time for no man woman ‏the time for
self here are
cler cler
ofer world
being so have
aect
own
ين and nobody
st you contin to fix yourself
‏days and
other person human
[Silence]
ح tri
‏not
[Silence]
‏anding
them اللهم لا اللهم لا ت غفرت ولاهم الا
فرجت ولا ك نفست ولا ميت الا رحمت ولا
مريض الا شافيت ولا دين الا قضيت ولا
اولادا الا اصلحت ولا حاجه من حوا دنيا رض
قيتها ويسرتها لنا اللهم كان رزقنا في
السماء فانزل كان رزق في الارض فاخرجه وان
كان بعيدا فقربه وان كان قريبا فيسير كان
قليلا فبارك لنا فيه واعلم ان الله قد
امركم امرا بداى في نفسه وسلم الاقدس
وسلمكم معشر مؤمن جنس قال عز ق عليما ان
الله وملائكته يصلون على النبي يا ايها
الذين امنوا صلوا عليه وسلموا تسليما
اللهم سلم وبارك و وعلى ابدك محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين عباد الله ان الله
يامركم بالعدل والاحسان واتا ذي القربى
وينهى عن فحشاء منكر بغي يعزكم لعلكم
تذكرون اذكروا الله العظيم ذكركم واشكر
زيدكم وذكر الله اكبر وقوموا الى صلاتكم
ارحمكم
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله اشهد ان محمد رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
اللهب الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
[Silence]
امين بسم الله الرحمن
ال و لكل زه
لمزه الذي جمع مالا
وعدده يحسب ان
ماله
اخلده
كلا لين
في
الحطمه
وما ادراك ما
الحطمه نار الله
الموقده التي تطلع على
الافئده
انها عليهم
مؤصده في
عمد
ممدده الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
بسم
الله قل اعوذ برب
الناس ملك
الناس اله
الناس من شر الوسواس
الخناس الذي يوسوس في صدور
الناس من
الجنه
والناس الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
السلام الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم و رحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏that
‏take ز